Euh, même les guerres, pardon, ont 1 règle.
Euh. Et euh. Le droit international s'applique euh.
Partout,
tout le temps et à tout le monde. Et donc, euh, à 1 moment,
euh. Israël fait la démonstration pour 1 énième fois
qu'il n'appliquera pas,
qu'il ne souhaite pas appliquer
cette décision de l'ONU,
à 1 moment, il va falloir passer à des sanctions,
c'est aussi simple que cela,
qui doivent s'organiser au niveau européen.
La France doit y prendre sa part, et les États-Unis,
qui contribuent lourdement à l'armement israélien,
doivent aussi arrêter
de fournir
des armes et des services militaires à Israël,
parce que, euh.
Mais vous savez ce que ça veut dire,
la justice
internationale nous dit qu'il y a 1 risque de génocide.
Et donc 1 moment,
quand on continue d'armée,
euh, 1 dans ce conflit où il y a 1 risque de génocide,
on s'en rend complice.
Donc on arrête d'envoyer les armes à Israël,
on sanctionne Israël à quel niveau ?
Bah ça c'est des discussions
qui vont avoir lieu de manière démocratique,
et qui doivent avoir lieu,
pour moi aussi au niveau européen.
Parce que ces sanctions ont bien sûr plus d'effets
si elles s'organisent au niveau européen,
que juste la France.
Mais la France doit mettre
l'affaire de lance.
Et je pense qu'on ne peut pas
continuer à laisser faire ce qui se passe à Gaza
en restant les bras croisés
et en disant, euh, bon, on aimerait bien que ça s'arrête,
on comprend pas. Pourquoi ça continue ?
On a des leviers à notre disposition,
il faut maintenant les actionner et faire peur.
D'un peu de courage,
la France doit renouer
avec la
position 1 peu singulière qu'elle avait au niveau euh.
International. À l'époque de Dominique de Villepin,
on était fier d'être français,
parce que la France
euh. Allait faire des discours,
on disait, ah bah merci la France,
on est fière d'être français.
Enfin, la France hier,
la France hier, a voté en faveur de cette résolution.
Euh oui, mais j'ai pas entendu.
Enfin, ça fait quand-même des mois que ça dure,
où la France est timorée, d'ailleurs,
finit par se fâcher avec tout le monde dans la zone je.
J'aimerais que la France fasse pause
d'un peu plus de courage et dignité.
Par exemple, c'est l'Afrique du Sud
qui a dû aller saisir la justice
internationale pour, euh.
Que la justice nationale dit ce qu'il y avait 1,
1 risque de de génocide,
euh. Pourquoi la France ne l'a pas fait ?
Pourquoi la France, avec.
J'ai demandé ça plusieurs fois après,
dans la République,
dans toutes les réunions,
ne euh se
mobilisent pas lourdement pour que des
enquêteurs de la cour pénale
internationale
entre à Gaza. Pas très compliqué comme mesure.
Ça leur coûte quoi
de demander ça ?
Que que juste la justice puisse enquêter ?
Moi, ça me pose 1 problème de
de transparence.
Je me demande ce qui se passe pour qu'il n'arrive pas
juste à dire ça
et euh, quand ? À appliquer des sanctions.
Je vois qu'on en est pas là, mais à 1 moment. Euh.
Ça me paraît très juste, normal,
on l'aurait fait pour plein d'autres pays.
On a d'ailleurs
fait dans notre conflit beaucoup plus rapidement